I get inspired by women that I meet
every day on the daily basis and you're
among them kamila Albus is the
definition of a boss lady juggling her
organic baby food line yummy spoonfuls
her website women of today and raising
her three little ones with hubby Matthew
McConaughey she stopped by et's Facebook
Live series boss lady to give us tips on
how she handles it all it's the most
rewarding thing when my kids come to me
and say you know I'm going to work and I
know you have that mom guilt my daughter
would come to me be like mama I'm so
proud of you that you're choosing to
help families feed what's healthy for
them and she's seven they know about all
of it they understand I explained to
them when we were doing you know making
the product I drove them over there and
show how it works and made them
understand all of it so they're a big
part of it and they taste tests
everything that we're yeah we're doing
doing all that you do what do you think
is kind of the one thing you try to do
every day to keep all those balls
rolling I like to keep my priorities
straight every day so my prayers are my
family my kids my husband my home and
then it go the list goes down from there
so at the end of the day as long as I no
matter what's going on and you know what
stressful thing or problems are
happening if I can go back to my
priority list and check that that helps
me keep it calm throughout the day how
has Matthew supported you in all this
because he's actually told us before
about how he applauds you on how
supportive you are because you always
tell him to follow his dreams and go do
the movie and you know go pursue his
passion how has he reported you you know
he's I mean you know my husband and wife
and you know and not only that we're
best friends and you know I mean like so
he was super supportive like he was you
know when I needed to do what I needed
to do he was right there
[Music]
you